ALLAN WEINBERGER: Ladies and
gentlemen, Gilbert Gottfried.
[APPLAUSE]
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: At least
keep clapping till I sit down.
Yes.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Gilbert,
thank you for joining us.
Over the past 40 years, you've
been one of America's leading
comics.
From backrooms of comedy
clubs, to Saturday Night Live,
to being in Disney films, you
are an exceptionally successful
actor as well as voice actor.
With that, you're also
quite controversial.
In 1991, you were
banned from the Emmys,
and presumably are the reason
why they are on time delay.
You were accredited with
being the first comic
to make a 9/11 joke on 9/29.
And you were publicly
released from your endorsement
by Aflac for making
tsunami jokes
during the Japanese tsunami.
So with all of that,
where should we start?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Well, never
take career advice from me.
That's the most important thing.
Yeah, any place you want to.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Well,
welcome to Google.
Is this your first time here?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: The what?
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
Welcome to Google.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Yes.
I just want to come back
here for the kitchens.
They have these big--
it's amazing, the kitchens here.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Yeah.
Right beforehand, I took
Gilbert to find some cookies.
And it was about a
20-minute expedition.
So let me ask you-- in
your 40-year career,
when did you get
your first break?
What was your first moment?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: I
got some false starts.
I was a cast member of
"Saturday Night Live"
in the season from
'80 to '81, where
it was right after the
original cast had left.
And back then, "Saturday Night
Live" with a different cast
would be like if, in
mid-season of "Friends,"
they changed all
the actors on you.
And said, just watch
the show, and just act
like they're the same people.
Now the cast on "Saturday
Night" changes in
between commercial break.
But that was an outrage.
They were panning the show
before it got on the air.
So that was awful.
And then my next big break
was "Thicke of the Night."
That was Alan Thicke's
talk show that
was advertised as it was going
to kick Carson off the air.
And if you notice, Carson's
not on the air anymore, so--
[LAUGHTER]
So he was right.
And that was a horrible bomb.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: [LAUGHS]
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: And
then, not even trying,
I was back to Catch
a Rising Star,
where I would go up on stage.
And someone saw me there--
this woman comes over,
she says, I work for MTV.
We're having some
auditions tomorrow.
So I showed up there and
started improvising stuff.
And next thing I know, they
just took the audition tape
and were showing it on MTV.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Did you
get paid for that, at least?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Well
that's another thing.
I call them.
And I said, should
I be getting paid?
Once I brought it up, they paid
me a couple hundred dollars.
And the minute William
Morris found out about it,
they took out 10%.
They had nothing to do with it.
But that was my
first big break--
the MTV spots.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: OK.
And then I'm always interested
in about how comics made it
to "Saturday Night Live."
What was your path there?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: I was
known as a stand-up comic.
And not big places, just
Catch and stuff like that.
And then they were
holding auditions.
So they saw me at
the clubs on stage,
and then they called me in
to audition in their offices.
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
And you had to do it.
Was it the tight five?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Yeah, I
don't remember how tight it was,
with the way I operate.
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
Well, that's great.
So throughout your
40-year career,
there's been a lot that's
changed in the world.
And we've moved a lot
to a digital landscape.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Yeah
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
We're here at Google.
How has digital, social media--
how has this
changed your career?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED:
Well, I've always
said I find the internet
makes me feel sentimental
for old-time lynch mobs.
[LAUGHTER]
'Cause you've got to admire
people in the old lynch mobs.
At least they had to put
their shoes on, go out,
get their hands dirty,
and actually do something.
Now it's these
lynch mobs where you
sit in your underwear
on the couch,
and you make up your own.
It's very strange,
because the business has--
the second I thought I had a
vague idea of how show business
worked, it all changed.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: With digital?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Yeah.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: OK.
And was this with
Twitter that came out?
Or was there anything
in particular
where you realized
it was a change?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED:
Oh, so many things
I don't even know the name of.
It's like if you were to say
to me, oh, name some big star.
So in my mind, it would be
Tom Cruise and Julia Roberts.
But on the internet,
there's people
who get 9, 10 billion
times the amount of views
that those two would
get, together in a movie.
And at comedy clubs
sometimes, they'll
get someone from
the internet, who
shows how he squeezes his
blackheads or whatever.
[LAUGHTER]
And he's there.
And it's a mob scene.
[LAUGHTER]
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
So now, if you don't
mind, when you have a bad set,
let's say, back in the '80s.
You tell a bad joke.
Maybe it's a terribly
offensive joke.
You regret it.
You never tell it again.
You kind of get off Scot free.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Yeah.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Kind of
changed a little bit now.
You tell a bad tsunami
joke on Twitter,
you lose a lot of money.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Oh, yeah.
It's all over the planet.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: How do
you feel about comedy, now
that comedians aren't
really given the right
to tell bad jokes anymore?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Yeah.
It's very strange,
because there's
a line that George
Carlin said, that it's
the duty of a comedian to find
out where the line is drawn,
and then deliberately
cross over it.
And now, if you cross
over it, it's forgetting.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Well.
Very true.
Then in that topic, we
hear it all the time
with a lot of new comedians
such as Anthony Jeselnik where
it's, is there a time
when it is too soon?
Or it is too taboo, you're not
allowed to touch that topic.
How dare you?
What are your thoughts on that?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED:
I kind of feel
like you could make an
argument for my case,
and say, I'm more
sensitive, joking
while a tragedy's going on.
[LAUGHTER]
Because at least when
I tell a joke, when
the tragedy is going on,
their reaction is, oh my god.
They'll start to laugh, and
then cover their faces, and go,
oh, I shouldn't be
laughing at that.
That's horrible.
This is a horrible tragedy.
So their reaction,
when I'm doing it,
is acknowledging-- yes.
This is a horrible tragedy.
If you're a good
person and you wait--
and you could do a Titanic
joke, and no one cares.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Sure.
Maybe not in 1914, but yeah.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Yes.
So if you do it now, to
show you're sensitive
and then time has past,
what you're saying is,
enough time has passed--
fuck all the people who
died on the Titanic.
[LAUGHTER]
And that's sensitivity.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: There.
[APPLAUSE]
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: And I
love when people say to me,
how can you make
jokes on these topics?
Aren't you aware of the
tragedy and loss of life?
And I always go, yeah.
That's where the
joke stems from.
[LAUGHTER]
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Now,
to talk specifically
about one of those moments.
In 2001, at the Friar's Club,
the roast of Hugh Hefner.
Very famous moment for you.
You told the first
9/11 joke-- or at least
the famous person that told it.
to a roomful of comics.
And all of them, within a
moment, they were just shook.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Yeah.
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
And then it was
thought that you continued
to dig a hole until you got
to the other side of the Earth.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED:
Yeah, I mean--
[LAUGHTER]
The audience immediately
turned on me.
And it was like--
ALLAN WEINBERGER: How did
you feel in that moment?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Oh, they
were booing and hissing.
One guy yelled out,
too soon, which
I thought meant I didn't
take a long enough pause
between the set-up
and punchline.
But oh!
I felt like if you
said, that time right
after I said the 9/11 joke, if
I was up there for 200 years
after that, I'd believe it.
That's what it felt like.
And then I go into
the aristocrats joke,
because I felt like
I might as well go
to the bottom level in hell.
[LAUGHTER]
And it turned it all around,
and they were howling.
They burst out laughing.
And one critic said
it was cathartic.
One critic said, it's like I
performed a mass tracheotomy
on the crowd.
Because people just need to
be able to laugh at times
like that.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Absolutely.
So you're working on
a few projects now.
The reason why
you're here today is
you have a documentary
that releases
tomorrow named "Gilbert."
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: I won't tell
you what the story's about.
[LAUGHTER]
It's kind of like "A Hat
Full of Rain" or something.
Later on in the
play, you go, oh!
That's what they meant
by hat full of rain.
Yeah.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: So we're
going to talk about your--
[LAUGHS] I don't even know
where to go with that.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Yeah.
[IN DRAMATIC VOICE] He died
the death of a salesman,
with his red velvet--
oh.
"Death of a Salesman."
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
We're going to talk
about "Gilbert" in a moment.
But you have a podcast.
Can you tell us a little
bit about your podcast?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Yes.
It's called, "Gilbert
Gottfried's Amazing Colossal
Podcast."
And it's me and my
co-host, Frank Santopadre.
And we concentrate
on old Hollywood.
Like the Hollywood of just the
old movies and old TV shows.
And in a certain
way, it's reminiscent
of like "The Love Boat"
or "Fantasy Island"
where these people--
either, one, you didn't know
about in the first place,
or two, you thought were dead.
And now you see
them and go, wow.
They're as good as ever.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Who are
you interviewing for these?
And how often are
you showcasing this?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED:
It's on every week.
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
Where do you record it?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: At
a studio called Nutmeg.
It's a voiceover place, mainly.
And we've had on Carl Reiner,
Dick Van Dyke, Bruce Dern,
and Judd Apatow was on--
he was the youngest.
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
Mainly focusing
on the legendary comics?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Oh, yeah.
Legendary comics,
actors, directors.
Peter Bogdanovich was on.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: So you mention
that this is filmed in your--
do you use this theater or this
studio as your voiceover stage,
as well?
Do you do a lot--
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: I've done
lots of voiceovers there, yeah.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: So do you
enjoy doing voiceover work?
Or do you prefer on film?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Oh, yeah.
As long as I can hold onto
the job for, I enjoy it.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: One thing
that I love about your voiceover
work is that you can take the
most boring, bland articles,
and turn them into
something hilarious.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED:
On the internet,
you could find "Gilbert
Gottfried Reads 'Fifty Shades
of Gray.'"
[LAUGHTER]
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Well,
we can't do that today.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: [LAUGHS]
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
I do love my job.
And I'd like to keep that.
But I did research probably
the most boring, bland piece
of Google literature
that you could read,
and it's our Q3 earnings report.
And I was wondering if you would
take a stab at livening this
up a little bit?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: OK.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: All right.
So if I brought this for you.
Now, this just came out.
We did fine.
So you might need
some reading glasses.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED:
[CLEARS THROAT]
[LOUDLY AND DRAMATICALLY]
"Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone,
and welcome to Alphabet's
Third Quarter 2017
Earnings Conference Call!
With us today are Ruth
Porat and Sundar Pichai.
[LAUGHTER]
Some of the statements
that we make today
may be considered
forward looking,
including statements regarding
our future investments,
our long term growth
and innovation,
the expected performance
of our businesses,
and our expected level
of capital expenditures!
These standards involve a number
of risks and uncertainties
that could cause actual
results to differ--
[LAUGHTER]
--materially.
For more information,
please refer
to the risk factors
discussed in our Form 10K
for 2016 filed with the SEC.
[LAUGHTER]
Any forward-looking statements
that we make are based
on assumptions--
[LAUGHTER]
--as of today.
And we undertake no
obligation to update them.
[APPLAUSE]
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Thank you.
Ruth, Sundar, if
you're listening--
I'm sure he's available.
I don't know if
we can afford it,
but it might liven up these
reports just a little bit.
So thank you for doing that.
So we're going to move into
talking about your documentary
that is released tomorrow.
But prior to doing that, we'd
like to show the trailer.
And then we'll be
welcomed back on the stage
with the director, as
well as Gilbert's wife.
So go on and play it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[LAUGHTER]
- Stick them in!
Now, further!
Up, up, up further, further.
Go as far as you possibly can.
Wait a minute!
Come back!
This one's clean!
[DRUM ROLL]
Usually I lose the
crowd quicker than that.
I must be slipping.
[BRASS MUSIC PLAYING]
- He's an actor, a voiceover
talent, and comedian.
- The great Gilbert Gottfried.
- I don't know how
I know Gilbert.
He's always been
in the Zeitgeist.
- You know his voice
as soon as you hear it.
- Oh, stop!
- He doesn't really
filter himself.
And I think that's why
people are drawn to him.
- The worst thing
you could say to me
is, don't joke about that.
See?
Not so funny when
it's your mother!
- He is one of the cheapest
people in the world.
- I think he's the only guest
that takes all the sodas.
- How does he ride a bus?
There's not people
on there going, hey,
I want to use the
bathroom on the bus.
I can't.
Gilbert Gottfried's in there.
- It's hard making a
career in show business.
It's even harder sustaining it.
- Stand-up comic's
life is-- oh, god.
It's not glamorous at all.
- I'm just doing anything to
avoid my regular act, which
I'm so tired of.
- People assume he's
his stage character.
That's the furthest
thing from the truth.
- He's a very sweet, rather
shy person off stage.
- It's quite amazing to
see him when he's not on.
- Lot of memories being here.
- My father-- he used to get
very angry about my brother.
- I dropped out of high school.
I'm sure my father thought,
he's the loser of the group.
- There's always
a little surprise
that he became a husband.
- Nice to meet you.
- Yeah.
- And a dad.
- Is your dad funny?
- Not really.
- He seems like a gentle soul.
But a gentle soul was not
usually loud and obnoxious.
- [LAUGHS]
- Gilbert's somewhere between
Mark Twain and a birthday
clown.
- There's an
explosiveness to him.
- He's the real deal.
[BRASS MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hey, I don't like the
way you're talking to her.
Come on, you and me are
gonna have to tangle.
And you too.
[DRUM MUSIC PLAYING]
- Fetch this.
- Remember, this
is a family show.
- Yes, I know.
That's the first
thing you told me.
[LAUGHS] That's the first
thing everyone tells me.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
ALLAN WEINBERGER: And please
welcome to the stage Dara
Gottfried and Neil Berkley.
[APPLAUSE]
Welcome.
So Neil, you directed this film.
NEIL BERKELEY: Yes.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: And
you pitched the idea.
How did this come about?
NEIL BERKELEY: I just
started telling people
that I'm going to make a
Gilbert Gottfried movie.
And I would tell anyone
that would listen,
I'm going to make--
no, I never tried to call
his agent or his manager.
Never reached out.
Never really tried to do it.
Just I started telling
people I'm going to do it.
And then one day, I was
walking down 6th Avenue
with this woman
named Astrid Dorf.
And she said, what's your
next movie going to be about?
And I said, oh, it's going to
be about Gilbert Gottfried.
And she goes,
well, that's weird.
And I go, what?
I was like-- oh, man.
She hates Gilbert Gottfried.
She goes, it's weird because
his wife is my best friend.
And they live right over there.
And so I had a drink
with Dara that night,
and met Gilbert the next day.
And he said, don't do this.
This is a bad idea.
[LAUGHTER]
And then, seven months later,
Dara called and said, look.
I like your movies.
I like you.
And we're not doing anything.
So just come out
with your camera,
and maybe he won't
notice you're here.
[LAUGHTER]
And so I moved to New York.
And I slept on my buddy's
couch for seven months.
And I would just go to
their house every day.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: And
before you started,
what was the one
thing that you wanted
to make sure you captured?
NEIL BERKELEY: My
goal with this--
I told Dara halfway
through, I said,
look-- all I really
want to do is make
a movie that comedians love.
I said, I just want to
capture what that's like.
And my goal-- and whether
we did it or not--
is to make the movie that
every comic has to go
see when they
start the business.
And I don't know if
we did it or not.
But that was my goal.
I wanted to capture what it's
like to be a comic who still
tours every weekend, who's
still in clubs, who's still
working and raising a family
after 45 years in the business.
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
And Dara, when you
had this first meeting, what
were your initial thoughts?
DARA GOTTFRIED: Well,
basically I met Neil,
and he offered to take
Gilbert out to lunch.
And anyone that wants to pay
for Gilbert for a free meal,
he's happy to--
ALLAN WEINBERGER: By the
way, in the green room,
he kept asking how he could eat
lunch here every single day.
[LAUGHTER]
DARA GOTTFRIED: He's serious
about this, by the way!
NEIL BERKELEY: I don't
think he's joking.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: And this
came up multiple times.
DARA GOTTFRIED: Seriously.
NEIL BERKELEY: We'll put a
piece of paper in the bag.
Just put your name
and number on it,
and Gilbert will call
each of you every day.
[LAUGHTER]
ALLAN WEINBERGER: I'm
looking at paperwork,
and Allen Seals walks in.
And he asks Allen the
same exact question.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: It's like,
if there's a free meal in it,
I'll have lunch with
the head of ISIS.
[LAUGHTER]
DARA GOTTFRIED: So basically,
he took Gilbert out for lunch,
and Gilbert came home.
And I said, how did it go?
And he's like, eh--
the food was good.
So basically he said, you know,
documentaries are basically
for when you're dead
or find a cure for.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED:
Or yeah, if you've
opened up a bunch of schools
in a third-world country.
[LAUGHTER]
DARA GOTTFRIED: So he
wasn't into the idea.
But Neil, I just felt really--
he's such a talented director.
I loved his movies.
His passion for Gilbert
was like no other.
And he just was really
passionate about this project.
He sent me a handwritten
note on parchment paper.
I mean, it was so classy.
NEIL BERKELEY: No one
does that anymore.
DARA GOTTFRIED: No
one does that anymore.
And he was very persistent.
And I finally said, Gilbert
couldn't make a decision.
And I finally said, Neil,
just come out for one week.
Try it.
If Gilbert's
comfortable, you'll stay.
And if not, at least
you said you tried.
And the next day he
was on the plane.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED:
Neil said to me,
he goes, I've always wanted
to make a Gilbert Gottfried
documentary.
And I said, well, you
know you should set
your aspirations a lot higher.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, start off with
a Yakov Smirnoff one.
[LAUGHTER]
NEIL BERKELEY: The first day
I shot, I went over there.
And Dara and the kids were going
to school, so no one's there.
And the elevator opens
up, and Gilbert's
standing there in his
bathrobe with a cup of coffee.
And I had my camera
and all my stuff.
And I said, I'm Neil, and
we met a few months ago.
Dara said I can come make
a documentary about you.
And he goes, oh.
And I said, did she tell you?
And he goes, no.
[LAUGHTER]
And then he just turned around
and walked away from me.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's weird, though.
The way I work is--
I shot it myself.
So it's just me and a camera.
There's no lights
or crew or anything.
So in my head, I'm
always thinking,
do they think this is real?
It looks like I'm
making a home movie.
DARA GOTTFRIED: That's
what's it felt like.
It didn't feel real.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Yeah.
It was like someone from TMZ
spotting you, and holding
a camera.
No crew, nothing.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: So you
act as his quasi manager?
Is that--
DARA GOTTFRIED: Yeah.
By default, yeah.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: By default.
So in the documentary,
and hopefully everyone
will watch it.
It comes out tomorrow.
In the documentary,
you're very endearing.
DARA GOTTFRIED: Thanks.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: And you
commonly ask, what are you
going to do in your act?
And is this Gilbert?
Is this an act?
Would you say that
that is a character?
DARA GOTTFRIED: I think
it's part of you, right?
It's not really a character.
It's just part of who you are.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Yeah.
It's very weird.
It's kind of like
Jekyll and Hyde.
And it's like, later
on in the story,
it's hard to distinguish
between the two of them,
because they keep
going back and forth.
And so I feel like
neither one of them.
You could say, OK, this
is the real one by now.
NEIL BERKELEY: You said
something interesting to me
pretty recently.
We were talking about
that, and people--
I've seen so many people do
horrible Gilbert Gottfried
impressions to
Gilbert Gottfried.
Don't do it.
Don't come up to him,
and don't do the voice.
Just avoid it.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: My
all-time favorite--
DARA GOTTFRIED: I
know what this is.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: I wish I
could go back and record it.
I was at a party years
ago, and OJ Simpson--
[LAUGHTER]
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Oh, my god!
He killed.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
And he was a fan of mine, and
decided to do an imitation.
And back then, you know--
football player, sometime
actor.
And now it would be like if
Charles Manson came up to me
and said, hey!
I'm-- you know the Tate murders?
Here.
Look.
Hi, I'm Gilbert.
[LAUGHTER]
Wow.
That's very good.
So if I could go back in
time, I would film that.
I wouldn't kill Hitler,
though, but I'd film that.
[LAUGHTER]
NEIL BERKELEY: One time you
said to me that sometimes you've
heard so many impressions,
that you think in your head
that you're doing a bad
Gilbert Gottfried impression.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Yeah.
It does get like, sometimes
when I'm performing,
I'll feel like, I'm
doing a really--
like anybody in the street could
do a better Gilbert Gottfried
right now than me.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Who does
the best Gilbert Gottfried?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Oh,
there's been a few I've heard.
Well, Jimmy Fallon.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: OK.
I could see him.
DARA GOTTFRIED: Oh, excellent.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED:
Funny imitation of me.
NEIL BERKELEY: We're putting out
an extended cut of the movie.
It's like 2 and 1/2 hours long.
And there's this
moment in Toronto,
which is in the cut, where
this guy is at a voiceover,
and he starts doing it.
And there's a really
awkward pause.
And Gilbert is eating a
sandwich, and he goes,
I can tell he's impressed.
And Gilbert goes,
by the egg salad.
[LAUGHTER]
And this guy just like melts.
And it crushed him.
[LAUGHTER]
ALLAN WEINBERGER: So this
documentary really hones
in on--
you're a family man now.
And your sense of humor--
I've never seen any comic
have such a wide range.
You're in "Aladdin,"
and then you're
known for the aristocrats joke.
Do your children listen
to your stand-up?
No.
They're not allowed.
DARA GOTTFRIED:
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
What's the ruling here?
When are they allowed?
DARA GOTTFRIED: They're not
allowed to see the movie,
and they're not allowed to--
GILBERT GOTTFRIED:
Until they're 57.
[LAUGHTER]
DARA GOTTFRIED: They've
come a couple of times.
Like the first five minutes,
you've kept clean, right?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Yeah.
And even then,
I'll find something
that seems a little obscene.
And it's funny.
My son, who's now
eight, he was asking
Dara when he was about
six or something,
can I go see Daddy's act?
And she said, no, he
uses a lot of bad words.
And he goes, that's
what makes it funny.
[LAUGHTER]
So he should be my
writer, basically.
[LAUGHTER]
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Do you think
they'll find it on their own,
now that computers
are the way they are?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Oh, I'm sure.
You can't-- there's no such
a thing as a secret nowadays.
DARA GOTTFRIED: But
are they interested?
Like the other day,
they had no interest
in coming with us to "Colbert."
They're not that
interested in us.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Do they
know how famous you are?
NEIL BERKELEY: Max
does an impression
of people taking photos of you.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Oh.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
We'd have to show that.
But it's such a good impression.
[LAUGHTER]
And he did it when
he was really small.
And he came up to me in the
living room and goes, oh.
Oh.
I'm sorry.
You're Gilbert, right?
I don't want to bother you.
[LAUGHTER]
Can we do a selfie?
And he had everything.
[LAUGHTER]
ALLAN WEINBERGER: So let's talk
about the release of the film.
NEIL BERKELEY: Yeah.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: When this
is getting released tomorrow?
What's next?
NEIL BERKELEY: Tomorrow night.
All of you should come
out to the IFC Center,
or go on Twitter
and tell everyone.
It's going to be at the
IFC Center tomorrow night,
and all week long,
all next week.
And then it's going to be in LA.
And then very soon
after that, it
will be on iTunes
and everything.
But come out tomorrow
and see it in theaters.
Because everyone says
this about movies.
But Doug Benson, if
you're any fans of comedy,
called this movie the
sweetest and filthiest movie
he'd ever seen.
And hearing those laughs.
There are very tender moments.
We get to meet
Gilbert's family--
his sister Arlene Gottfried.
I've been plugging you guys,
because when I tell this story,
I say, everyone go
Google Arlene Gottfried.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Photographer!
NEIL BERKELEY: Because she's
a brilliant photographer.
She took some
pictures of New York--
it's the bombed-out,
Lower East Side,
scary New York that
doesn't exist anymore.
So please go look her up.
Oh, yeah.
IFC Center tomorrow.
Gilbert and I will
be there with Dara.
Ira Glass is going to be
there hosting our Q&A's.
Artie Lange is
going to be there.
So it should be a
really fun night.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: And you know
how reliable Artie Lange is.
[LAUGHTER]
ALLAN WEINBERGER: So
we're going to open up
to questions in one moment.
So if you do have a question,
go ahead and get ready.
What's next?
Oh, yeah, what did you want--
NEIL BERKELEY: Gilbertmovie.com.
When you're telling all
your friends to go see it.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: What's next?
What does the next
couple of years
look like for you, Gilbert?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED:
Arthritis, gout.
[LAUGHTER]
Looking at my own kids
going, who are you?
What?
Where am I now?
ALLAN WEINBERGER: All right.
Arthritis and gout.
We'll end there.
We'll open up to questions.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First of all, I'd like to
say, thank you for coming.
I just wanted to ask.
So I've literally
grown up hearing
your voice in "Aladdin,"
"Dr. Doolittle,"
"Cyberchase" and everything.
I was wondering what your
favorite animated work
was to do?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Well,
certainly the work on "Aladdin"
is right up there, because it
was the most successful thing
I've ever done.
[LAUGHTER]
And Disney hasn't fired
me over the years.
But that, and then
smaller stuff.
I remember I was
on "Ren and Stimpy"
as Jerry, the belly button elf.
[LAUGHTER]
I think I was an ant in
an insecticide commercial.
And a toaster in a Pop-tarts ad.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: What was
this shoe gazey thing you did?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Oh!
Yes.
This, I did one of
these commercials
for one of those
products, those classic
"As Seen on TV" products,
where they convince you
you can't live without it.
And this was a product
called Shoe Dini.
[LAUGHTER]
And they showed, at
the beginning of it,
you'd see these old
people struggling
to put their shoe on or off.
And they'd be falling down.
And as long as you didn't
ask the first question, which
was, well, why didn't
they just sit in a chair
when they're putting
their shoes on?
But it was a shoehorn
with a stick.
You basically-- a
retractable shoehorn,
which-- how you lived
without it all these years.
You'd press the button
and pull it out.
So you'd put on
your shoe like that.
DARA GOTTFRIED: Then how
do you tie your shoes?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: That
they didn't explain.
[LAUGHTER]
That-- I'm sure they're
selling another one
with two robotic hands.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Gilbert.
It seems like today, a comedian
has to constantly put out
content to stay top of
mind-- whether it's Twitter,
or YouTube, or what have you.
And my impression of the way
it might have been 30 years ago
or something is that
you could actually
work on a piece of
material for six months,
and then come out and
do a show or something,
and it would kind
of last longer.
Is that accurate?
And how do you feel about
today versus back then?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED:
Well, it's funny.
When TV first came
about, the big fear
was that all these old
Vaudevillian performers who
had been doing the same
act for like 30 years
would now be on TV, and
it would be eaten up.
And TV is nothing
compared to the internet.
And if you're working on
a bit, before you've even
developed it, it'll
be all over the world.
Because people are there
with these recording devices
that could fit in a
ring on your hand.
So it's that strange.
AUDIENCE: Gotcha.
Right.
Thank you.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: That didn't
sound like a good answer.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
We're going to move
to this side of the
room really quick.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: All right.
I tried.
[LAUGHTER]
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Go ahead?
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Can you talk a little
bit about your voice,
and how you found your voice
as a writer and a comic?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: That's
just through years of going up
on stage every night.
I never trusted these places
that say they teach comedy.
It's like, you keep going on
stage over and over again.
You bomb like crazy.
And then eventually,
it comes about.
Like when people
say, how did you
develop your whole delivery?
I never really consciously
thought, OK, I'm
going to do it this way.
To me it's like, if you
see someone walking down
the street sipping
a cup of coffee,
and you went over and said, you
know, the way you hold the cup
and bring it--
how did you first
come up with that?
[LAUGHTER]
ALLAN WEINBERGER: To add
to that question-- what
do you recommend to comics and
aspiring comedians who are just
starting out or
looking to get into it?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Yeah.
That's just basically it.
You find these clubs
that don't pay anything,
and you just keep going
there with the hope
first, that they'll
let you on stage.
And then, if they do, just keep
trying as much as possible.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you all for coming.
That was actually my question.
So this question's--
GILBERT GOTTFRIED:
So get out of here!
AUDIENCE: I know.
[LAUGHTER]
Dara, how did Gilbert propose?
DARA GOTTFRIED: Aw.
That's really sweet.
Well, we dated 10 years
before we got married.
It was a long courtship.
And finally, I just
said, let's get a ring.
And he said, I saw an ad
somewhere in Hackensack.
[LAUGHTER]
Where they have
them really cheap.
And I was like, don't worry.
We don't spend too much.
And then-- [LAUGHS]
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: That
was the selling point.
[LAUGHTER]
DARA GOTTFRIED: And
then we were at a zoo.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: No.
There's no love here, but we
won't have to spend any money.
[LAUGHTER]
DARA GOTTFRIED: Anyway,
we were at a zoo
in Calgary, because
he loves dinosaurs,
and they had a dinosaur exhibit.
So it really wasn't
that romantic,
to be honest with you.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, we're engaged.
Here it is.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was just wondering--
for the filming of
the documentary,
how did it impact your life?
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: It
was one of those things,
like I hated doing it.
[LAUGHTER]
And I hate watching
it, which Neil loves.
DARA GOTTFRIED: But
you like the movie.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Yeah.
Well, when I watch
it, I'm like, oh god.
Because I'm OK watching
myself as like Nick
the plumber in a sitcom episode.
But to watch me as me, I--
it's kind of like how
people, when they first
hear their voice recorded,
or see themselves on film,
and they go, oh god.
I don't look like that.
And I don't sound like that.
And there are scenes in the
movie where I look at myself
and I go, do I really
walk like Fred Sanford
in "Sanford and Son"?
Like, you big dummy.
[LAUGHTER]
DARA GOTTFRIED: But like I
said, I shot it by myself.
So it's really just--
Gilbert and I, we went to 15
different cities, and Toronto,
and Mexico.
So it was really just
like tagging along,
and I just happened to have
a camera every now and then.
Yeah.
The first time we traveled,
we went to Philadelphia.
And I called Dara
and said, I'm going
to go to Philly with Gilbert.
And she goes, OK, you need
to go get a Megabus ticket.
And I was like, what
are you talking about?
And she goes, yeah,
he takes the Megabus.
I don't know if you
know what that is.
It's an $8 ticket to
anywhere you want to go.
It's like Philly,
Baltimore, and DC.
And she goes, oh, also,
don't tell Gilbert,
but I spend three extra dollars
so I can get him a seat up
front on the upper deck.
[LAUGHTER]
She goes, don't tell
him, because he'll
tell me not to spend the money.
[LAUGHTER]
DARA GOTTFRIED: It's true.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: And Neil
is the most Gentile film
maker you'll ever meet.
It's like, he
would come up to me
and say, what does fakakta mean?
[LAUGHTER]
And two days ago,
at my apartment,
he was he was holding
something in his hand
that he found on the table.
And it was a little
plastic dreidel.
And he was holding
it and looking at it
like a caveman
looking at an iPhone.
And with fear in his eyes,
he goes, what is this?
And he goes, do
you play with it?
And I said, yeah.
I don't want to
talk to you anymore.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
Quick question.
We live in this weird
world right now,
where you have overly
political correctness,
and then our leader
says what he thinks.
And you've made a career out of
saying the controversial thing,
or potentially what's on your
mind, and in a great way.
Just kind of curious
to get your thoughts
on this weird world we're in
and political correctness.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Yeah.
Well, I'd like to think that
when Nixon was President--
it was when the whole hippie
movement was going strong,
and there were student
protests, and there
was drugs, and orgies,
and everything.
Skinny-dipping.
[LAUGHTER]
And it's like all these
different protests.
And Nixon was saying that
there's a moral majority
that he believes in.
Like, these are
the troublemakers,
but the majority is moral.
And I like to think there's
a majority of people who have
a fucking brain in their head.
[LAUGHTER]
When you see these
people who have
to complain and get outraged.
I still like to
think most people,
they know what a joke is.
And also I feel
like, say there's
a big disaster, a tragedy.
You can actually go
there and help out.
Or you could write
out a generous check
and send it to them.
Or you could get offended
by a joke that someone made.
And then sit back and
pat yourself on the back.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
ALLAN WEINBERGER: And
for our last question.
AUDIENCE: Hey, there.
I've been listening to
you for a long time.
On "Howard Stern,"
they had you come on,
and you're known impressions.
They would have you
do double impressions.
I was wondering if you
would give us, perhaps,
a Jerry Seinfeld impersonating
perhaps our current president
or a former US president.
NEIL BERKELEY: Can I just
set this up real quick?
There's a theory that I've
heard from other comics
that Gilbert invented
the Seinfeld impression.
And Richard Belzer told
me this story about
how Gilbert would go
on in the early '80s,
before Seinfeld was "Seinfeld."
And he would do Seinfeld's
whole act as Seinfeld.
[LAUGHTER]
While Seinfeld was there.
GILBERT GOTTFRIED:
And Seinfeld--
the other comics and wait
staff would run into the room
while I was doing this stuff.
Seinfeld would stay
out in the bar,
angrily pacing back and forth,
going [IMITATING SEINFELD] that
doesn't sound anything like me.
[LAUGHTER]
But in answer to your
question, Seinfeld as Trump.
That would be
[IMITATING] well, I
say, with the Nazis
and the protesters,
both sides were wrong.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
ALLAN WEINBERGER: All right.
Thank you very much
for joining us.
We're going to be here for a
few more minutes, if anyone
wants to help Gilbert
steal some food.
[LAUGHTER]
GILBERT GOTTFRIED: Any of
you have a large knapsack?
[LAUGHTER]
ALLAN WEINBERGER: The
movie comes out tomorrow.
Please go and watch it.
Thank you guys very much.
NEIL BERKELEY:
Thank you very much.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Thank you.
That was a lot of fun.
[APPLAUSE]
DARA GOTTFRIED: Thank you.